Welcome back to Outer Wilds Echoes of the Eye!
The Eye!
Oh my goodness.
Time to get comfy and lurk in this lovely stream.
Hi Mint, hello!
Parasocial.
Yeah, how else to ghost?
Thanks.
Yeah, welcome back to Outer Wilds Echoes of the Eye.
Not just a single echo, multiple echoes.
I'm a little scatterbrained because I had so much going on today.
But I'm excited to continue this.
This is part two out of probably three.
I think today will be a little bit shorter of a stream because...
I've talked a lot today actually.
So...
Even before this, my throat was feeling a little...
A little...
Not hurty.
A little sore.
So...
Will it be uploaded to YouTube?
The stream?
Vocal cords a little strained?
Yes.
You could say a little strained, a little parasite-y.
Vocal parasites.
But um...
I'm thinking maybe like three hours.
And then we'll finish it up next week.
In a part three.
YouTube content on YouTube?
Of course not!
Did you find the egg?
The egg.
You guys, the egg that...
Yesterday I thought I saw an egg.
The egg of the universe.
Might be four streams?
No, I think I'm gonna endurance it next week.
Yeah.
I'm gonna endurance it.
So, don't worry about it.
Um, the egg...
Was an egg!
It was a real egg.
It existed.
It was on the screen.
It was a real egg.
It was an egg!
It's gonna be really endurance-y though.
We'll see!
I looked it up!
Why did...
Oh my goodness.
My chair.
Why did it say that the DLC is like 10 hours then?
Everyone's making it seem like it's a 50 hour DLC.
Echoes of the eyes.
Let's resume our expedition.
Depends on the person.
Smart!
Right!
Oh, let's wake up.
Good morning!
So, I'm trying to think...
There was one place in particular from yesterday that I really want to go to today.
It's the one location that I keep missing.
Hold on.
Oh!
Let's view the ship logs a little bit first.
As a recap.
The Stranger.
We found the Stranger!
It's an artificial ring world hidden within some sort of cloaking field.
Real...
Mint words.
Not Wikipedia copy-pasted.
It is not Hearthian or Gnomian.
Yeah.
And...
We made a very large deal.
Jeffrey!
That's okay.
It's worth...
My money's worth, right?
We went to the radio tower to find it.
Was it the reservoir?
Oh!
Look at this.
An enormous reservoir with wooden piers and buildings on both shores.
I found a room with a burned control interface and a projection that seems to indicate a broken connection between the Stranger and another craft.
I found a projection showing the Stranger's current trajectory and the Sun's predicted supernova radius.
That's right!
It was moving away from the Sun!
I saw a building marked with a unique symbol.
I think this is the one that I wanted to go to.
Recessed into one of the canyon walls, but the bridge that used to lead to it has rotted away.
Oh.
I found several ornate metal artifacts inside a workshop surrounded by ghost objects.
Yes!
We went in there!
Okay.
But this cliffside building is what is...
There's more to explore here in the reservoir.
Oh.
Well that's just like...
Yeah.
What's...
Oh no.
That's all the old stuff.
Okay.
But no egg to... There was an egg!
They just haven't said it yet.
Uh.
Map?
...
Where are you?
This isn't it.
Uh.
Hold on.
View the log again.
There we go.
Mark it on...
Okay.
There we go.
Have fun playing!
It's my birthday today!
Mr. Albusy!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy...
Why isn't it letting me autopilot?
Happy birthday Mr. Albusy!
Happy birthday to you!
Oh cause I'm not locked on it.
Oh.
Here I come!
I'm coming in hot!
Stranger!
Hello?
Um.
Can you stop moving for like two seconds?
Uh.
Oh.
Nope.
That's up.
I need to go up.
I'm matching the velocity!
And we also found some secret... Oh wait.
Am I upside down?
Again?
How does this keep happening to me?
Just roll.
Perfect landing!
We found some secret ways to get in.
I wonder if there's any other secret ways then, you know?
No?
Okay.
It's actually a great landing.
I know!
That's what I'm saying!
I always land perfectly.
On two feet.
I'm like a cat.
I can't see anything!
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
Turns out indeed does show during intended directvp.
Oh!
It is!
We missed it!
Thanks for the info though, Nan.
Thank you.
What?
Stop!
Oh!
Oh, we're here!
Oh, we went inside this one!
I didn't even realize.
Okay.
Um...
Let's rotate this.
Alrighty.
On the road again.
Sorry about the lock on...
No!
It wasn't you!
It was me!
Jeffrey, don't apologize.
You have nothing to apologize for, buddy.
Look!
This one is not the one that I wanted to go to.
I believe.
This one...
No.
I think it's further up the road.
Woo!
Makes my stomach drop a little bit.
My stummy.
Yeah.
I've been around here for quite a bit.
Oh!
Wee!
This part is so fun.
Okay.
It's past here too.
I love the music here.
I also...
I've noticed that there's like a back side to this.
A behind.
Tower's got a big ol' behind.
No.
Oh!
Be careful!
We gotta hurry before everything starts breaking apart.
Here!
There!
That's the one!
That's the one, right?
I believe.
Oh god!
Maybe not this one.
Actually, maybe I'm a liar.
I'm a liar.
But there is that up there!
Wait a second.
Oh!
Yes!
No!
This is the one!
I'm not a liar.
I've never lied.
I've never lied!
But the gap...
That's right.
There's a big ol' gap.
What if we...
Ouch!
We're fine!
I thought it was Minecraft rules.
But if I land in the water, I'll be okay.
Come on!
Move!
Maybe I can propel myself up here.
A little bit.
Okay.
Nice.
And whoop!
Nice!
Whoop!
Vitals are low, but does it really matter Who needs bones?
Not me.
I'm a ghost.
Um...
Hmm...
Whoop!
Uh-oh.
Guys...
Oh, like there's a way up here.
I heard it though.
I hear that.
Where is that coming from?
Hmm... I guess we'll continue onward.
Push!
Come!
Hmm... This game is scary.
Hahaha!
It's a little eerie, right?
Wowee!
I mean, we...
We saw some pretty freaky stuff before.
Oh, I thought that was a door right there.
Um...
Could there be another way?
What's over here actually?
Because...
I think there's only one way to get through here, right?
Like, where does this lead to?
Where am I crazy?
Go!
Power through!
Power!
Oh...
It's not strong enough.
Hmm...
But how do we get over through there?
Right?
That might be our way.
What's over here?
Hmm...
You might be crazy.
Hahaha!
I might be crazy.
So that's...
Cause...
Oh, I see it right there.
We have to go on this side and then very quickly go through here.
Because there's all this stuff...
I don't think I've been to those, right?
Those buildings over there.
Hmm...
I don't think so.
What if I just...
Hahaha!
Where does it land?
Is it in the water?
I think it's in the water.
Ha!
Oh!
Nice!
Hahaha!
I can't tell at all if I've been here or not.
I can't tell even a little bit.
Aww...
This might have been a waste of a run.
But maybe not a total...
Maybe not a waste is dramatic to say, right?
Maybe...
Cause we learned...
Well, nothing.
Hahaha!
I learned that I will try to get to these buildings there.
Can I climb through the trees like a monkey?
Speaking of monkeys...
You guys...
Uh oh.
I'm gonna die.
Oh!
I lived!
Speaking of monkeys...
I have a new high score in Bloons.
Which is like...
A hundred and...
Eighty something.
Hahaha!
No monkey!
I think I'm gonna meditate.
Thank you for always being yourself, Mint.
Is that a good thing?
Thanks, Dylan.
Mm-hmm.
Actually, no.
I think I lied.
I think not 180.
I think it was 178.
But that's also closer.
To... 200.
She lied?
I don't lie!
I've never lied.
What about Ice Monkey, though?
He's a given.
Yeah-wee!
Goo!
Okay.
So we're going to go down that one.
And we're going to go on the right side.
And we're gonna keep to the right.
Keep to the right.
When she lies, her nose gets smaller.
Reverse Pinocchio.
Is it gonna send us inside?
No.
There we go.
Comin' in.
Comin' in easy.
Am I upside down again?
I think I am.
Why am I always upside down?
Here I am!
Do a flip!
I wonder...
Let's see.
Nice landing.
I think I'm a professional now, for real.
Oh!
It is!
It is this one.
Oh, but it's not here.
Oh, man.
Ah!
Awesome!
Here we go!
She's a professional now.
I know!
This spooky little house.
He almost repeated the elevator.
Where was this house at, though?
Actually...
I can't quite remember.
Oh, no!
Wait!
We're at the damn...
Oh...
Oh, shucks.
We need to go all...
You know what?
That's fine.
Cowabunga!
Easy.
So, maybe it wasn't the most effective way.
But that's fine.
Give me in!
Here we go!
On the road again!
What was that about?
This not being Minecraft?
It wasn't!
I very much jumped into a deep...
pit of water.
Okay, not yet.
It's past there.
Okay.
Oh, I...
I see it!
Oh, goodness!
It's really tough to get all the way over there.
Okay.
We'll do our best.
Maybe if we, like, propel ourselves from over here.
Okay.
This way.
Over yonder.
Okay, we got this.
We got this.
Just stick to the right.
Stick to the right.
There it is.
The hidden passageway.
Nice!
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
We're gonna learn more things!
We're gonna learn so much over here.
We're gonna learn all the knowledge in the world over here.
To the right!
There we go!
Nice!
Straight in the middle there.
So many eggs on the screen right now.
Stop!
Stop this!
Stop this humiliation, please!
What do we have over here?
An elevator.
Come down!
Oh, it's broken.
Just kidding.
Don't fall through.
But we have to find a way to get up there.
Okay, that's...
Question number one.
Don't get crushed again.
We have a thing here.
In an ancient language.
This game be wild.
Yeah, it's so awesome though.
There we go.
Oh my goodness.
New places are so exciting to explore!
So exciting!
Cups!
And such.
Minto gear solid 5.
The phantom egg.
Oh, that's where we just came from.
Okay.
Oh!
Time to go see more culty activities!
This one.
Wow!
There we go.
This way.
There better not be some dead guys down here.
Or else I'm really gonna start thinking that this is a cult!
I'm really...
I'm serious this time.
Uh oh.
Wait!
Were they always wearing necklaces?
Or am I just now noticing that for the first time?
We have to figure out what's going on here.
We're on definitely a time limit.
I mean, I've always been on a time limit.
But we gotta know what that sound is.
We gotta figure it out.
Kulto.
What necklaces?
You didn't see them?
Oh, is this another...
Nice.
I have the artifact!
I wonder if I combine this...
With something.
I must combine it.
Uh oh, wait.
I need to get a...
Pick it up.
I need to go find a lantern, but I don't know where to get one.
...
Oh...!
JoJo и JoJo & Komaro Happy birthday to you...
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Chojo-ko!
Happy birthday!
Oh, the cult room.
You're so right.
Let's go get a lantern.
I had like 50 in the creepo room.
You're right.
There's a lot over here.
This is exciting.
There's so much going on over here.
Now, can I combine the lantern with the artifact?
No question.
In fact, I'm gonna go grab it real quick.
We're gonna bring you upstairs.
You're mine.
Conceal?
Wait, what does that mean?
Oh, focus?
Interesting...
Didn't, um...
Sorry, hold on.
I'm thinking.
Didn't we, um...
Conceal, don't feel, don't let them know.
Well, now they know.
Um...
There was like one thing that we lit up that, um...
That showed like secret passageways and stuff.
Remember, it showed like the secret, uh...
The secret, um...
Cave.
So I wonder...
If that is what that does.
Hmm.
Okay.
We're looking at this, this thing again.
So scary.
Oh gosh.
Again!
Okay, he lights it up.
The third one!
The third eye.
Okay, so the top one was the first eye.
The second one is the second eye.
And the third one is the third eye.
Okay.
Why did I leave it on that one again?
It's so scary.
Jeffrey, are you guys okay?
Why is this game...
Why is this DLC so much scarier than...
Than everything else?
Yes.
That's the thing.
That's the artifact.
Your guy is kind of giving Portrait of God vibes.
Don't say that!
It'll scare me so much!
Stop!
Nano!
What's wrong with you?
Just go back!
excited It's over slaughtered.
Damn it!
I'm gonna go death Oh, man.
Oh, my God.
He sees me!
Why is this guy's voice so코 wasn't supposed to give me a chance to see him getting worse?
Then, how dare you prof dismiss the Pope really?
Hey, bro!
Huh?
What I'll do?
Oh, my God!
I didn't reduce my gauge.
He's scratched out.
He's blinking.
Vtuber.
No, we hate those planets.
We're watching our own planet instead.
Our planet rocks.
Yeah, our planet's so cool.
Our planet's the best planet.
They're crying.
They missed their planet.
That's so sad.
Woo, our planet!
Our planet.
Oh god, why did we leave our planet?
It's just, who's taking this video of them crying about their planet?
I have a feeling I used the artifact on these slides.
I'm scared!
There's so many of them!
Oh, the room!
It's the room where they...
Where they...
Wait, can I light it with the...
They're crying because their oshi is late to stream.
No, who would cry over that?
Who would cry over that?
Hello?
They're looking at me.
Good night.
And it lights up.
And they fall asleep.
They're asleep.
Okay.
Eepy baby.
So this guy...
If we take it into that room, what will happen?
Artifact does not fit.
Oh, wait.
I'm a little afraid to see what happens.
Time to nap!
What if I go into the room that had the one ...
The one bed that was opened for me?
I'm scared!
I'm scared... I'm scared.
I was scared!
I'm so scared!
Sit on fire!
Light on fire!
Eat a marshmallow first.
Perfect!
Mmm, yummy!
Anyway...
Yeah, all of theirs are lit.
This guy...
When the melatonin hits!
This guy too!
Dang!
Are there...
Are there spoilers?
I will not look.
I see you guys posting some...
What just happened?
Don't touch the fire so much, I guess.
Maybe I got a little too close.
I like that you guys do the four eyes smileys for this game.
Minto, what if you died?
Be careful out there.
Okay.
Let's continue onward for now.
Now...
Hmm...
This is an elevator.
No, no, no.
Up.
It does not go up.
It only goes down.
Hey, go down.
Go down!
Is this not where I...
Oh!
This is the elevator!
Okay, never mind.
Go up!
Go up, elevator!
Yeah, this is the broken one.
Good to know.
This leads to nowhere.
I don't know how much time we have...
left.
Are those the... that's the...
Oh, the reels are all burned up though.
It's all burned up.
Oh!
Uh...
Am I...
I was gonna say, am I in trouble?
Do we have to come back here when it's...
Um...
When that happens?
Uh-oh.
Wait, no.
It won't flood here, will it?
Am I in trouble?
Uh-oh.
Uh...
Am I in trouble?
Hahaha!
Um...
Any rush of water?
Oh!
Here it comes!
Yeah!
I'll hide right here.
I hear it, I hear it, I hear it.
You're in so much trouble, little miss.
Oh!
I wonder if it floods in here though.
Dang, it doesn't.
That's me!
Okay.
Hmm...
Bye-bye bridge.
Oh no!
We didn't get to go to that side!
Hahaha!
Oh man!
Um...
Uh...
It also took the entire house down.
Hahaha!
But we have this house to go into.
Still?
The entrance doesn't have radiation.
What do you mean?
I wonder if I do picture mode.
Oh gosh.
That's like really close though.
Yeah.
Oh!
I don't think I can go any further.
I don't think so.
For now.
Does this eat?
Wait.
It's the same color.
Focus.
I don't want to die though.
When we're at the end...
When we're towards the end, I'll come back and try it.
I think.
We'll just leave it there for now.
I want to look inside this place real quick.
Oi!
Oh!
If I can.
Wow!
Nice place you got here.
Why is it locked?
What are you hiding?
Huh?
An axe!
What are you hiding?
Do it after the music starts.
Yeah.
Something like that.
There's a whole lot of...
Nothing.
There's a whole lot of nothing in here.
Just kidding!
Oh my god.
I'm so scared.
Wait!
That's a thing right there!
That's a...
That's a reel!
I'm so scared of seeing somebody.
Right there!
We need that.
Yeah.
A slide reel.
I wonder if I can get the door from up here.
Like, you know, with the light.
Maybe here.
Launch!
Oh!
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Take it back!
Too slow.
Okay.
Launch!
No!
Take it back!
Launch!
Yippee!
I told you guys I'm so smart!
Minto tensai.
I know.
I know I am.
Oh, this is a new picture.
They're playing... Oh my gosh.
They're literally playing 4D chess.
Minto tensai.
The...
projection room was...
over here.
That honestly took me way longer to figure out.
Oh, it depends on the person.
How long it'll take you.
I have my moments of strokes of genius, okay?
Thank you.
Drop.
Insert.
Incoming four hours for one puzzle.
That's why I'm saying there's strokes of genius.
What is this?
It's something.
It's a gate?
Why is the music so scary?
I'm trying to tell what's that at the bottom.
There's so many of these.
There's nine of them.
Minto matter.
I can't read it.
Okay, something bad happened to it.
I just got chills down my spine.
The music is so eerie.
It makes me quite afraid.
I'm observing each slide, each little individual pixel.
Okay, it's scaring me, so I'm gonna just let that be.
We got the ship log updated, at least.
Is that an egg?
Yes!
How'd you know?
How much time do you think we have left?
There's also... that's... oh!
Oh, that's the... that's another artifact.
The little lantern symbol.
Do you think I can make it?
Hmm...
You think I can make it?
You can totally make it.
Do it.
For science.
But what about this guy?
This is our first time finding an artifact that we can pick up.
What if I bring the real in here, though?
Because it's the real room.
For real homies only.
Hold on.
I'm gonna go get the real.
And see what happens.
Because it's the real room.
The room of reals.
Like this one.
We'll just pick up this one.
Wait, this one already was all burnt up.
Wasn't it?
We'll take this one.
What would that accomplish, though?
It could... I think we have to burn it.
So then once we use the artifact, we can see new things on the real.
On the slides that... because this one had no burns on it, right?
So I think it would... it will reveal more stuff when we use the artifact.
Uh-oh.
Oh, it's time!
It's time!
Drop!
Wait, uh...
Okay, I need to get it a little closer.
Drop!
Okay, that didn't do anything.
Oh, I died.
I died.
Okay, well, we know that didn't do anything.
You dropped dead.
Wait, there's more to explore in that area, though.
Bam!
Oh, you know what I watched recently, um, on the plane?
I watched, um...
I talked about it before on stream.
But I've been thinking about it quite a bit.
It was uh...
All you need is kill, but what's... I can't remember the English name.
Um...
Uh...
Not Top Gun.
Not this time.
Edge of Tomorrow!
Yes!
And every time in this game when you're like...
It reminds me of when he wakes up in Edge of Tomorrow.
I really liked that movie.
I really liked it.
Live, die, repeat.
I love time travel.
I love things where you have to die and relive the same day.
Groundhog's Day.
You're playing the My Tom Cruise.
An enormous reservoir with wooden pi...
Oh, wait, that's the same thing.
Hole breach.
Oh, I found a slide reel in the hidden gorge...
that showed an explosion blowing a hole in the side...
of the stranger.
Yeah, that's totally what that showed.
Does that mean we should enter from there?
Instead of entering...
See, okay, that bottom part down there, I was like...
Oh, that kind of looks like the entrance I've been going in every time.
I see.
I did recognize it.
That's why I was looking at it.
It looks like the part where I've been entering...
from entering the stranger.
A narrow gorge along the rightmost branch of the river.
There are dwellings built into both cliff faces high above.
Several reels...
A slide reel that shows the stranger's inhabitants...
congregating around a strange green fire.
Several slides have been burned and cannot be viewed.
Oh, a slide reel from the hidden gorge showed...
a glowing symbol and the chains appear around a strange...
fault.
Ooh, scary.
Don't forget to read the lines.
Oh, you're right!
There are line things too, aren't there?
Oh, whoops.
A slide reel from the hidden gorge shows a glowing symbol...
and chains appear around a strange vault.
A slide reel from the cinder aisles shows a glowing...
someone!
Chains appear around...
It's just the same thing over and over again.
Wait, what?
A slide reel from the river lowlands showed a strange...
strange vault being closed and sealed with chains...
and a glowing symbol.
I like, yeah, I really do like that it shows the reels...
because then I don't have to go back and find them all over again.
The reservoir, there's more to explore here.
Oh, in the, okay, the reservoir.
Yes, because there's that house that we haven't been able to go into.
I wonder if I can figure, there was the doors that were locked?
I wonder if it's similar to the puzzle I just did...
with the light, like, shooting my, like, my little scout in there.
Okay.
Solid Mint!
That's me!
I played this DLC and it did not have that feature.
Yay for quality of life updates!
Yippee!
Getting the reels to play back in the ship vlog was an unusually hard problem to solve...
for later DLC patches.
I want to try...
real quick though.
I do want to go back to that one spot, but I want to try and...
find...
the explosion part.
The part that...
blew up, right?
It was...
Wait, if I'm looking at it upside down...
Okay, hold on.
It's on, it's up here, right?
It's like...
Eep, eep, eep, eep, eep, eep!
Oh, over here.
I'm getting all...
topsy-turvied.
Oopsie.
We're fine.
Everything's okay.
This side.
We're okay.
Gosh, stranger.
I can't move...
to the right.
I can't.
I can only move...
I can only move a little bit forward.
Oh.
No.
Eeeep.
You know what?
I'm just gonna land right here.
Let's go look at the log real quick.
Eeeep.
Okay...
Okay, it's the very outmost...
And it's...
Oh my gosh, it goes so fast.
It goes so fast.
I need to see the whole thing!
Ship's a little roughed up.
It's okay, we can fix it!
Okay.
I think I got it.
Oh!
Goodbye ship!
Over...
This one.
Maybe.
Do I have a flashlight on or what?
Why do I have a flashlight?
This is fine.
This one?
Ouch.
Um...
Where did my ship go anyway?
All the way over there.
It's that one up there, is it not?
No.
Up, up, up, up.
Girl is so lost.
No.
I'm not.
It's this one.
In the corner.
Don't, don't run into it.
Right here.
But my flashlight is not working for some reason.
Um...
Wait!
What just happened?
Huh?
Did I go too fast?
I was coming in a little hot.
I came in... a little hot.
Sometimes it's really hard to tell how fast you're going.
When you feel like you're just going so slow.
Okay, one more time.
Oh, wait.
No.
Okay.
A tad hot.
We got it this time though.
Remind us not to accept rides from you.
Look!
It's harder.
It's harder to tell when you're not...
Using your actual body.
I think I would know how fast I was going if I was using my real body.
My spirit.
Okay.
Let's see.
If we're looking at it...
So it's that one over there, right?
Perhaps.
Perhaps it's this one.
I'm gonna land slowly.
Keep the velocity matched.
Land slow.
Can I even land actually?
I don't even know.
Oh...
Yeah!
Perfect!
It's that one right there, right?
I think so.
Please be it.
Did I find it?
Wait.
What's going on?
What just happened?
I didn't find it.
Now...
Oh, shoot.
I think I'm lost again.
You guys...
That was really weird.
And my flashlight has stopped working again.
What's happening?
Why can't I move?
I'm trapped.
Okay.
There we go.
Ouch.
I can't...
You scout for me.
That's a good plan.
You guys are so smart.
I don't know why my flashlight has stopped working though.
I can't even find it.
I'm so confused.
It's...
Here?
Maybe.
I made it.
I lived.
I
lived.
I lived.
But I don't see the hole.
I don't even...
Why am I sideways?
How do I fix myself?
Oh, road...
Wait.
How do I fix myself, you guys?
I'm sideways and I don't know how to get up.
Outer edge.
Okay.
I'm sideways.
Oh.
Over here.
I'm sideways.
I keep...
I'm trying.
Go, scout.
Go.
Why am I being pushed away so far?
Help me.
I'm afraid you're unfixable.
Shut up.
How do I get in there?
50% fuel remaining.
Oh.
This is so...
I made such a mistake.
I'm trying to go down.
But I come in too high.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh.
Wrong down.
I'm stuck.
This thing is so...
Oh, no.
I didn't mean to take the scout back.
I'm trapped in a hole.
Why is this thing so large?
Oh, my God.
Ouch.
Hole.
I'm stuck.
Oh, no.
I'm inside.
Oh.
Got it.
Leave.
I don't like that.
Oh.
Okay.
No, pick up.
What's this?
It's a working thing.
Let's open this.
I think.
Wait.
Huh?
Close the door.
It's gonna show me secrets.
Oh, my bad.
Wait.
Close the door.
It's gonna show me secrets.
I think my scout is ruining it.
There's no secrets.
No secrets.
Okay, interesting.
Hello?
Oh?
Where are we?
Actually.
Uh-oh.
The light thing just happened.
Ah!
Where are we?
Oh, new picture.
Nice.
Cute little hmm.
There are secrets somewhere... There to be discovered.
Oh!
Stop.
I keep grabbing that.
Put it away!
Oh!
Oh grab it.
Sit down.
Lock yourself in.
Look at the fire.
Close your eyes.
Become one with the fire.
Okay!
I guess I'll do that!
Sounds good!
Oh, okay, I see now.
So, this part was damaged, but what happened in here?
There must have... there was an explosion!
So now we know what this room is for.
What happened in here?
What caused the explosion, you know?
Maybe it's a toilet.
For some reason I thought... wait, was one of these fires lit or am I crazy?
I think I'm crazy.
Oh, I'm getting absorbed again.
Let me leave!
Okay, there we go.
I'm trying to grab the artifact.
I don't think it really matters.
What about the other one?
Side-reel.
Okay, we're definitely gonna have to come back here because I...
I took too much time getting in here because I was lost, okay?
What about this one?
A regular lantern!
And you sit down... and you close the door...
And then... you close your eyes... and you see... the fuzzies.
It also works with a regular lantern, I guess?
Okay.
Interesting.
There's the regular one.
Okay.
Let's head out.
Oh, just a window.
That's what an idiot would say.
Just a blank?
No.
Nothing is ever just a blank.
Where are we?
We
made it to the other side!
And the bridge is intact!
Yippee!
There's like shortcuts everywhere.
Okay.
I was thinking I should've taken the boat in there but...
Actually, it's good that I didn't.
Okay, cool.
Let's go in here.
We need to hurry because we need to go to the other side.
In fact, I'm gonna drop this here.
And I'm gonna go get a lantern right now before this bridge disappears.
Let's go get it.
Run!
Run.
Rub.
Do you think you're fine on time?
I don't think so.
It's actually close-ish.
Because the electricity thing happened, which we still don't know...
I don't know what that is.
Still not sure.
Is this always there?
She has no confidence.
Have confidence.
Yeah, gotta listen for the damn break.
Okay.
Hmm?
Lamp.
Grab.
Grab it.
Firmly grasp it.
Show your friends.
Lock yourself in the room.
Look.
Be a little voyeur and observe.
Fall asleep.
Melatonin.
Wake up really quickly.
Speed nap.
Never mind.
Oh.
Use the artifact.
Do the same thing.
Fall asleep.
Speed run.
I can see like lanterns very slightly.
Like the lamps.
Something's going on in there.
Oh!
Is that the explosion?
Trees?
It's so hard to tell what's going on.
Oh.
Grab this thing.
Observe.
Speed nap.
Yes.
This is the thing.
It can't be a lantern or a circle.
It must be... that.
Okay.
Interesting.
So this... these ones here.
The one with the little... spikies.
Okay.
Hi cutie.
I hope you're doing well.
Dust call my wife!
I hope you're doing well too.
Hahaha.
We have to fall asleep in a room.
With the artifact.
Do we have to grab the artifact and go into that one room made for one?
Where was it?
It's at the very beginning though, right?
I don't think... I definitely don't think I have time for it now but we'll try.
Grab you.
Here we go.
It was...
Try the room nearer to you?
I needed like a chair to fall asleep in though, right?
I think... actually no.
I don't think I took this in there, did I?
Now that I think about it.
Oh my god.
Cult party!
Hey guys!
Everybody ready to slumber!
Oh god!
I'm scared!
I thought we were buddies!
I thought we were buddies to slumber!
Yeah!
Hahaha!
What are we screaming at?
Cult slumber party!
Officially welcome to the DLC part 2!
Ah!
Jeffrey!
I'm scared!
I can't even use my... I just realized I can't even use my thing.
I can't use my suit.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm lighting up the...
There's like little candles.
I'm lighting them up.
What?
Wow!
I'm on their planet!
What?
I think?
It's really dark.
I can't see anything.
That's why I keep focusing.
Because I can't see anything.
Thing.
Okay.
Light up.
Light up, light up.
This is...
Oh!
There's nothing dangerous in here!
Wow!
At least I didn't draw on your face and sharpie him.
I think it's so cool because I never used the doze off thing.
But then I was like...
Wait a second.
I can doze off here?
For real?
That's what they... They keep telling me to fall asleep.
And that's what I did and it worked!
What?
Where is everybody?
Oh.
They're... They're musical creatures.
Developers cooked.
I know!
Because in like the main game, it just feels like a way to kind of like pass time if you need.
If you need it.
If like you want to like have things go faster.
But...
It's actually like a mechanic here.
It's so cool.
Okay.
I'll go downstairs.
I'll search down here first.
Yes?
I just heard a door open.
I'm scared.
Guys, are there jump scares in this?
Be honest.
Freaking out a little bit.
Oh, that's a tree.
It's not there.
I don't remember jump scares.
I do remember regular scares.
There is a setting for reduced fright.
There is!
There is actually a setting for that.
I
got grabby grabbed.
Wait.
Oh.
I guess... I guess I saw everything there that I wanted to see.
This place... I don't think we're alone, you guys.
He's... He's watching VTubers.
I'm a little afraid.
Oh, God.
Wait.
I could meditate until next loop.
So there's still loops then.
Are there?
They're family.
Family.
Will they actually kill me?
What is that?
Oh, God.
I'm so scared.
There's something in here.
But I can't go in.
Oh, wait.
Is this...
No way!
The loop music!
It's so faint.
What?
It's... It's him below.
I think it's this guy.
How do I get in there?
I'm trying to go say hi to him.
I don't know how.
They play music.
They can't be bad.
Right?
Wait.
Is this where I came from?
I'm a little confused.
I'm getting a little lost.
So we are still technically...
Gosh.
Do these people not believe in light?
How are you supposed to see all the time?
This is... Okay.
Okay.
That's...
It's nighttime.
So!
Looks like, uh...
Like a creature that's like...
Bleh, bleh, bleh.
Okay.
We are going to die any second.
There it is.
Okay.
What the...
I was doing like...
It's a monster.
So I'm guessing also, if I do this at a separate little area, like a separate cult area, I will awaken in a different spot.
So let's try.
You really figured out a lot that loop.
Yeah we did, for real.
And then there should be more to explore, right?
Damaged laboratory.
I feel like we got so much more than it's actually showing.
A laboratory with three test chambers.
A second chamber is badly damaged and can be entered through a hole breach in the side of the stranger.
I saw a vision-like recording of someone picking up an artifact and going to sleep in front of a green fire.
The rest of the vision was distorted and difficult to make out, but a flame seemed to appear inside that artifact.
I found a slide reel.
Oh, whoops, my bad.
That shows three experiments conducted with three different artifacts.
The third experiment appears to have been a success.
And here.
A massive canyon that stretches into the distance.
A candlelit lodge is built into the far cliff face.
There's more to explore here.
But also, there's more to explore here.
At the reservoir.
So maybe we should go back here.
In fact, I think that's where we...
I think...
There was another, um...
Cult place there.
So...
That's a pretty good place to start.
I agree, I agree.
Oh my gosh, this DLC is crazy!
I was like... I was like, it's a little eerie, but like, I'm not seeing what's so scary about it.
Now I'm terrified!
Thanks a lot.
Team.
Thanks a lot, team.
Oh, we're coming in hot.
Eeeep!
The roll never...
Oh!
Oopsie.
Oh god.
Sorry, I didn't mean to kill you...
Through suffocation.
Whoopsie!
Oh no!
Thank you for membership.
There we go.
I'm playing along.
Did the same thing.
Have I ever used the eject function on the ship cockpit?
I haven't.
I don't think so.
Here we go!
Welcome to the ship, thank you!
Bravery duck, thank you!
I believe that Mint will find the egg.
I think so too.
Ooh!
Coming in a little hot.
Alright, we're gonna roll, everybody.
Roll!
Perfect.
There we go!
I like watching my shadow over here.
Everything is so big and so small at the same time.
Okay, cool.
This is where we need to be.
This is the ravine.
And we're going down.
Going down the bayou.
Taking it all the way.
You guys, stop saying there's an egg.
Only I can see them.
Okay?
Anyone who says that they see an egg is a liar.
The egg is only through Minto vision.
This one.
Now...
Is the guy...
Is the guy that we're seeing...
in the other world...
Is he the one that didn't go to sleep?
Uh-oh.
I have to go find an artifact.
So that's what I'm on the way to look for.
Artifacts!
Um...
Maybe...
It was in here.
Artifact.
That's a real...
Oh...
He hatched from the egg.
Hahaha.
Ah...
I see an egg head in the bottom right.
Ay-ay-ay-ay-ay-ay.
Ay-ay-ay-ay.
Was there an artifact around here?
Or...
Are we gonna have to go searching a little bit?
What did you not explore here while it was dry?
That's a great question.
Um...
I don't remember.
Hahaha.
Um...
Up here, perhaps?
No.
This just leads to...
A boat.
It's there dancing.
Hi, Mint.
First time here.
Hello!
Thanks for dropping by.
Hello.
Um...
We're playing Spooky Games.
Uh...
I'm a little frightened.
Right now, I'm fine.
I have seen the artifact!
You are so correct.
I do remember.
We have to return to the egg location.
It was under the water.
I...
Or no, it wasn't.
Murphy, thanks for the tank gift.
Hehe.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Um...
If I go down here...
Minecraft logic!
We're fine.
Everything's good.
Uh...
Maybe not the best location for that.
Um...
Whoa!
Oh my god, my eyes!
Wait a second.
Um...
Maybe I can go there?
Okay.
What?
Okay, we're safe.
There it is.
Oh no!
It's like...
Oh, just kidding.
There it is.
Okay, bye.
Just kidding.
Everything's fine.
Egg.
Did you see it?
Oh!
Hello?
Did you see it?
There's more to explore here.
But I feel like I mean...
Not in...
This creepy area way, right?
Wait, this isn't the one.
This isn't the one that's missing a guy.
Okay, interesting.
I don't know.
Where...
Which one was that then?
Time to doze off.
Time to wake up!
It was at the other tower.
They won't even let me roast a marshmallow here.
Okay, focus.
Also, why do I need to conceal sometimes?
I don't like that.
I don't like that at all.
Is there stealth in this?
Be honest.
Oh, no.
Give it to me now!
Give it to me straight!
If there is, I'm gonna cry.
Oh, there we are in a different location.
What did I miss?
Did she redact or redact yet?
Probably one of those.
There is actually sneaking in this?
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
My least favorite thing ever is...
is horror game sneaking.
It's actually one of my least favorite things.
Oh, no, no, no.
I have bad news.
Popping in to say hi before I get sucked into a black hole of work.
Music.
Thanks for the super chat!
I hear whistling.
It's coming from this way though.
I can't help but be silent because I'm so scared.
I'm so scared.
Is it breathing?
Do I hear breathing?
Okay, let's just keep going.
I'm so scared.
Let's just follow the lights.
I'm scared.
Why are these guys evil though?
Why are these guys going to want to kill me?
How do I get up there?
Guess we're going down.
Who says they're evil?
Well, then what's going to kill me?
It's all in your head.
You ever think how cute it is that she's always bringing her over here?
My tummy's starting to hurt.
Extinguish.
Okay.
Why can't I extinguish them?
Why?
What's over there?
Did you guys hear that?
There's something walking in the water.
Wait, how do I get back up?
Uh oh.
Wait, I don't know how to get back up.
Monster.
Monster, can you show me how to get up there?
Hello?
Don't say hello back.
I think that was the dam breaking.
What just happened?
Huh?
Oh my god, I'm trapped.
In a bell.
Where am I trapped?
Oh gosh.
I don't think I can get out from there.
Oh.
Get me out of here.
There's bodies.
Oh.
Oy oy oy oy oy oy.
Did I get caught?
Oh my god.
You do not recognize the bodies in the water.
You
do not recognize the bodies in the water.
Now what?
I'm expecting to get jumpscared from Mint getting jumpscared.
I'm sorry.
It's just what happens, you know.
I scream, you scream.
Oh wait.
Wait.
I think my fire went out.
I think my fire...
I think the water...
Wait, but I didn't walk in the water, did I?
Hmm.
The water in here.
Ah.
The water walked into you.
Did it like...
Did exterminating this fire cut it out or something?
Ah.
I see.
So maybe...
The tower...
I need a boat.
Come here!
Maybe the tower...
Will be free of...
Excuse me.
I'm hopping in.
Oh.
Let me in.
Let me in, please.
Thank you.
Okay.
The tower there.
That's the one that was missing the person though, right?
Don't play this carefree music...
As if you didn't just...
Scare the shit out of me before.
Don't just act like this is some...
Funky river boat ride.
Don't act like everything's normal.
Don't be like this.
It's like...
La la la.
So whimsical.
Here.
Wait.
How do I get up there?
And then we have to do it...
Before the tower falls.
It falls down.
I remember.
We don't have much time then, I think.
I don't think we have much time.
Jump.
It falls
right at the end of the cycle?
Okay.
There.
I'm too scared for this.
I'm too much of a baby.
Where are we now is the better question.
Hello?
If you're gonna kill me, just do it now.
Pull me out of my misery.
Sorry.
You guys, there's actually Stealth in this?
Don't lie to me.
Please, be honest.
Be honest.
I'm too scared.
Hello?
I don't like the whistling.
You play Metal Gear, I'm sure you're fine.
I don't...
Like Stealth!
I'm...
I've said that since the beginning.
I've always said that.
What's this music?
What's going on?
What is going on?
Maybe I should go down.
Hmm.
Okay.
They're on to you?
Stop!
Oh wait, I can't go down.
I just realized.
Can I see it from here?
I can't.
Nothing here.
Ah!
No!
Oh, gosh.
Get me out of here.
There we go.
Ah.
Oh.
What did you do this time?
Nothing!
It wasn't me!
Ah.
We didn't get to explore very much there.
We learned so much.
I guess we did learn that if you...
If...
If the water...
If the fire goes out in this world...
Then it goes out...
Uh...
It goes out in...
Then we get forcefully removed.
Okay.
So next loop...
We'll come to this tower.
Okay.
Next loop, we'll come to this tower.
I'm so scared, though.
I'm too scared.
Brain is bigger.
Do something cool before it's over.
Yeah!
Um...
Nice jump.
Nice egg.
Whee!
Are we good?
There it is.
I know I can meditate, but I like listening to the music.
I just gleeked all over the place.
Nasty!
I am feeling a bit better today, though.
So...
I think that's good.
Maybe I'm getting better.
Huh?
Yeah.
I gleeked.
Restart!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Can't I just stay here, Slate?
The world!
The universe is too terrifying!
I don't like it anymore!
Meat is fries.
Minced thighs.
Hot dog surprise.
Thank you!
I can gleek on command?
On demand?
All these people are demanding me to gleek!
Do you gleek ectoplasm?
Just a little bit, yeah.
Ooh, she's got bars.
Alex, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
I can't stop yawning, though.
I think because I...
I woke up early.
It was a busy day today for me.
Oh, shoot!
I forgot to check, though.
Um...
Okay, hold on.
Once we get inside...
Oh my goodness.
Coming in hot!
And roll...
Nice.
There's one thing I forgot to check, though.
Here.
Interesting.
Mint, can you gleek, please?
I can't do it on command!
A secluded village nestled within a cave.
A candlelit tower sits atop a nearby island.
I can't tell what anything is because everything is so dark.
A dense forest along the banks of a river.
Okay.
This is the one that I couldn't get back up on the, um...
What's it called?
The bridge after we did it.
How am I supposed to...
Maybe I'm supposed to jump.
I don't know.
Okay.
And we still have this cliffside building that we couldn't make it to.
The bridge, yeah, had rotted off.
So we have to go away.
And wherever this sealed vault is...
And...
The reservoir still says there's more to explore here.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
Um...
What?
More is there to explore in the reservoir?
Oh, the reservoir!
Just kidding.
I keep thinking of the, um...
The first area that we came out of.
Hello, universe.
Ahhh!
Let's go.
Take me back.
I'm so sorry, everybody.
Too much universe.
Yeah, that's the reservoir.
I keep thinking this is the reservoir right here.
Okay.
To the tower!
Because we'll have the most amount of time to explore.
There.
So I want to go back.
What did you think?
I didn't think I...
I didn't think it was going to force me off.
I thought maybe I would just be looking at the universe.
I thought maybe.
Stop judging me, everybody.
Okay.
Look at all these eggs.
Wow.
Nice.
There's one around here, but I forget which house it's in.
What do you mean, one around here?
An egg?
Oh!
The artifact!
Um...
Yes.
We must find one.
Shoot.
Uh...
I thought an egg.
I've only got egg on the brain, everybody.
Um...
We can find it, though.
Yeah, see?
This guy with his antler broken off.
Do you think he's the one that, um...
Do you think he's the one that's stalking the knight?
I have to watch out.
My throat is starting to hurt.
Oh, no.
They said you abandoned us.
So they crossed out his picture.
He's not worthy any longer.
Is there...
Is there one around here?
Oh.
I'm really glad I tuned into the stream.
I didn't realize they made DLC for Eggos of the eye.
Eggos.
Um...
You can backseat if you want to tell me because nobody knows where it's at.
Just so we can progress.
Is that a baby?
Small.
There's no...
There's none here?
I don't think there's any artifacts here.
Oh, no!
The one in the ghost matter building upstream.
Oh, shoot.
So we came all this way for nothing.
Okay, so now we know the order of operations must be...
Grab artifact.
Head to tower.
The minty.
Eggos.
I wonder if I can...
Upstream or in the canyon?
Canyon.
If I go upstream, how do I get back here?
Wait.
Was there anything else over here?
I don't think so, right?
Come on.
You can make it.
We weren't traveling fast enough for the music to believe we were playing the game.
It's a loop.
Oh.
Well, yeah, but...
It was here, right?
Oh, wait.
Wait, I'm confused again.
What is that thing?
What is destroying the power?
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
Please, please, please, please, please.
I think I went to the wrong place.
Oh, shoot.
Shoot.
I'm a little lost, I think.
I think I'm a little lost.
Yes, hold it.
Yes.
Actually, I do want to see this place again.
Because...
This is where...
I wonder if we can use the scout here.
Go over the dam and grab it.
Yeah, I think I'm gonna have to.
Because it says there's more to explore in here.
But can we...
Is there like a mirror or something?
Maybe here?
No.
I'm gonna go out on the lake a bit next time you come through the transition from one theme to the other.
It's my favorite bit of sound.
You're like, hey, can you just not play the game for a second?
Oh, wait, here!
Maybe.
Uh...
Wait a second, does that mean I have to go in under the water?
Ah ha!
Okay!
Good stuff.
There we go.
Okay, we finally made it in here!
Yippee!
Huh?
Wait, there was a lantern here?
Oh, sorry.
Oh!
It's inside!
Oh my gosh!
It's inside that bell tower thingy!
The seal!
The safe!
Good info!
We got some actual good info here.
Come on!
Don't be so picky.
Okay.
What is this?
That?
Is it?
There was a way to lift it, perhaps?
Control it in some way?
Okay.
Okay!
That was a good...
That was a pretty big find, I'd say.
Hmm.
Which maybe we wait for it to drain.
Or?
Not.
Oh!
Maybe we should wait for it to drain.
Or?
Not.
Oh!
If I had an artifact here!
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
If I had...
If I had an artifact here...
This is where we will doze off next.
Oh!
And it's safe from water!
You're right!
Hazard.
It is made of ghost matter.
It is made of ghost matter, actually.
No wonder it looks like it.
Okay.
What's up?
Thank you for the podcast.
It's been really helping me through my work day.
Thank you, Don!
Thank you.
I'm glad you're enjoying it.
Thank you for listening.
Okay.
Um...
Uh...
Guys, you'll have to remind me.
How do I...
get up?
You have to remind me where another artifact was.
There wasn't one over here, right?
I think we have to wait for the dam to break.
Well...
There was one by the egg.
Yes!
Yes.
Maybe I shouldn't wait.
Maybe I should just go.
I think I'm gonna fly down.
I think I'm just gonna fly down.
Oh!
Nevermind!
Hahaha!
Uh...
Here we go!
Kaboosh!
Look at it lowering.
So cool!
So, so cool.
So I'm guessing whatever powers off or whatever happens here is what causes the um... wait.
It's here, right?
Where is the ghost matter place?
Ghost matter!
Where's the matter?
Oh, there it is!
Okay, nice.
Um, I'm guessing whatever explodes or like messes with the power is what causes the um...
the dam to break.
That's my hypothesis.
Also, so the ghost matter is nullified by water.
So that one makes sense why the fire is also...
Hi!
Can I...
Do I have to loop all... I think I have to loop.
Let's go.
Let's go quickly.
I haven't watched much because I still want to play the game myself, but I hope you're doing well.
Stop by and send some love and support.
Thank you, Kinky!
It's getting crazy.
Oh, oh, that's a tree.
I thought it was just a bush.
Is it normal fire or nullified by water though?
Oh, we didn't know what the ghost matter was before.
So...
You know...
It's...
So it's a ghost fire.
A will-o-wisp.
I'm starting to get kind of hungry.
Over...
Okay.
Now here's where it's tricky because the...
The current seems a little strong here.
Oh my god, we're going to doze off in here?
And it's not going to be some terrifying thing?
The creepy guys, right?
It's going to be normal probably.
It's going to be great.
It's going to be less scary than the other ones.
Because the guys disappear in the other ones.
Matara gone.
There's an elevator.
Okay.
Okay, I guess we got to go down.
A hole.
Aha.
Wait.
Those are the locks?
Those are the locks.
For Matara.
We're going to lock her up.
Use interface.
Oh no, I don't know the password.
Oh, I don't know the password.
Okay.
That's...
Oh, there she is.
Hi.
Secret language.
Rotate.
Oh.
There?
What's there?
I'm having visions, you guys.
I'm having some crazy visions.
There?
Take that.
Aha.
Okay.
In the tower.
Fall asleep.
Good night.
Aha.
Wait, what?
What?
What did that mean?
Where are the subtitles?
Mr. Meaty Cougar.
Welcome to Mavishif.
Thank you.
I got stuck on this for like two hours.
That...
was a little confusing.
Wee-woo.
Aye-aye-aye-aye-aye.
I was busy there.
Excuse you.
I was working on stuff.
I'll just go back.
Who are you to stop me, huh?
Yeah, that's right.
I'm just gonna go back.
Oh.
Good.
Yeah.
We're fine.
Let me actually wake you up.
All right.
Maybe if I can seal my...
my flame instead.
I'm not sure...
Oh, the candles are still lit and everything.
I guess they stay that way...
for the cycle.
How do we get...
the codes for these?
Hello?
Oh.
It's time, everybody.
I believe.
It's time.
Run!
Just go!
Just run!
Oh!
So cool!
It goes to the normal music now.
No, we'll listen to the music.
And then I'll die.
Bling!
Marshmallow at the end of the world.
You know it.
And cooked...
to...
perfection.
Actually, I prefer mine burnt.
Ow!
Eat ten burnt marshmallows!
Mmm, carcinogens...
is the...
is the achievement.
Huh?
Oh.
That was weird.
I meditated...
and I woke up in...
the other world.
Because you slept at the fire.
I meditated at the fire.
Wait, can I do that?
Instead of just looping?
I mean, instead of dozing off?
Very cool.
It's a nice little touch, right?
Submerged structure.
Subterranean...
Subterranean animism.
Subterranean lake.
A large metal structure...
is suspended by chains.
It can be entered by swimming from below.
A sealed vault illuminated by green fire...
inside the structure.
I discovered a vast...
subterranean lake beneath the...
submerged structure.
The sealed vault is resting on the shore of the lake.
There are three interfaces, each marked with one of the three symbols...
from the vault.
I rotated the mechanism in front of the vault, causing it to...
strain against the chains holding it shut.
Moments later, rays of green light...
spilled out of the vault.
We're just gonna totally ignore the...
the hallucinations.
I got it.
I got you.
Oh.
I found a strange vault...
wrapped in chains and marked with three glowing symbols.
Slide reel from river lowlands...
showed... oh yes.
Oh, wait wait wait.
Slide reel from the hidden gorge showed a glowing symbol...
and chains appear around...
a strange vault.
Okay.
The light coming out from the vault...
showed a vision...
Oh, here it is.
Here's our vision.
A vision of climbing a spiral staircase...
to a room near the top of a tower.
One of the stranger's inhabitants...
pointed at a mural of an identical tower...
beneath a ringed planet.
Then picked up an artifact...
and carried it downstairs to a room with a green fire.
Sometime later...
two of the lamps in the mural room turned off...
plunging the mural into darkness...
and revealing a secret passage.
The passage led...
to three wooden containers...
each marked with a glowing vault seal.
Okay.
So...
What I'm...
Can I just move the...
the glowing?
Let's go back to that tower...
and check it out.
Seems like some people are...
saying that they are getting stuck on this part.
Hahaha.
We'll see about that.
Let's see if we can figure it out.
Cause it's...
I have to go?
Wait.
If I...
go down with the artifact...
do I have to fall asleep?
I'm not quite sure.
We'll experiment.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Velocity.
Coming in hot, coming in hot.
Eating Mike Tyson's ass.
Thanks for two months.
And thanks for the five...
gifted.
He's eating ass.
Will it always...
be Mike Tyson's ass?
Or...
Is that just what you prefer?
It will forever be MTA.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Um...
We'll just use the raft.
Go over here.
In fact, I'll just...
dock.
I'm getting quite good at that.
It will always be...
Mike Tyson.
Hahaha.
Understandable.
Minecraft.
Physics.
Oh!
Ouch.
We're fine.
Oink.
Grab that.
See ya.
Important game breaking spoilers.
Mince cute.
Oh, how do I...
get back up to my boat?
Oh, just kidding.
Okie dokie.
Let's ignore that spoiler.
Mods, ban the spoiler.
Ban the person...
that spoils.
Um...
We're going back to the tower.
The tower to the tower.
Hahaha.
Over here.
This is where we were trying to do before.
Wasn't it?
Okay.
Here we go.
I don't remember.
What was in this cave?
Actually can't quite remember.
Oh, that's right.
The secret stairs.
Can I like...
Wee!
Okay.
We're just gonna...
We're just gonna brute force it here.
Nice.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Nice.
So basically, he goes and looks at the picture.
He says, Nice picture.
And then he goes down and lights the fire.
And then he...
goes back up.
Do you think calling Minto cute as a spoiler is like saying Romeo and Juliet?
Is it tragic?
Being a tragedy is a spoiler?
No.
What do you mean?
I saw this one.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, so we need these to go out.
Eventually.
Okay, so I'm looking at it.
Wow.
I'm looking.
I'm viewing.
Okay.
What's up here?
The top of the world.
Oh, that's right!
Here!
This is the one spot we haven't gone to.
I think.
Oh.
I think I can just jump.
I think it's fine.
Let's go over here.
It sounds like it's coming from over here.
Like the sound.
But this thing doesn't stop spinning.
Does it?
No, I don't think so.
It's the egg.
Enough with the egg!
No, it's still spinning.
Hmm.
I
feel like I'm not doing this correctly.
But I'm still... there's an attempt.
Come on.
Use your legs.
Do I doze off?
Oh!
I hate being here.
I can't extinguish it.
Oh lordy, I hate being here.
I hate this so much.
So...
This is the tower.
We have to get back some...
Wait, can I just...
Can I just wake up?
And then I go back up, right?
So then we go...
Wait!
Okay...
Let's see if this worked.
Maybe?
I'm not sure.
Oh, wrong way.
My eyes become wide when I'm focusing.
It's cause I'm scared.
Stop it.
Sorry they have big buggy eyes.
No!
It didn't work.
Hmm.
Destroy it.
Destroy!
Launch!
Hmm...
This one took me a while.
These are different types of lamps, so I don't think they break in the water.
I mean, they should when the whole tower comes down, but you know.
Hmm...
Do I have to spend more time in there or something?
Or...
Maybe the more lights... Well, no.
I was gonna say the more lights I light up in there, the ones turn off out here.
Does the tower on the other side have a room like this too?
I don't think I could access it if it does.
Hmm...
But I think the...
Oops.
It's this door that opens though, right?
Because it's... this is the one that it showed.
It said that the lanterns turned off in here and then the door opened up in here.
True, but it did show the guy carrying the artifact out.
What, like it was lit up?
I can't remember.
It gets me every time.
Hehehe.
Aaaaaah!
I wish I could see the logs.
Ohoho.
Hmm...
Big yawn.
Oh, my EP.
Also, my throat's starting to hurt a little bit.
Not a little bit, a lot of it.
Check the reel.
Check the reel?
The one that I just left?
It'd be convenient in here, especially since it's tough to get back to the ship.
Yeah, I think that's the only thing.
Um...
If I have to meditate, that's okay.
Oops.
What was in here?
Can't remember.
You've seen the reel.
Yeah, I know.
But...
I have to, like, look at it again.
Oh yeah, okay.
Ah...
I could go get it and look at it here.
Try and figure it out.
Let's just do that.
Is it this one?
Wait, is it this reel?
I don't think it is, right?
It's not this one, right?
This one just shows, um...
I think that one showed...
Okay, I think we need to look at the other one.
Because that one, if I remember correctly, it shows how to get into the secret room in here.
By getting rid of the lanterns.
Yeah, that one showed the trick with the paintings.
Yeah, so there's no point going back into there.
Um...
Wow!
Okay, I'm surprised I made that.
I don't like the music in here at all.
I'm just like you guys!
That means you should leave me alone!
Hmm...
Oh, wake up.
Let's see.
I can't fly around so much.
So...
I can't drop into the water probably.
I don't see...
Let's see.
Maybe we can see from here.
I don't see any like hidden...
Wait a minute...
Wait!
Wait just a darn second!
That one over there?
How am I supposed to get there though?
Hmm...
You think I can jump?
You think I can make it if I jump?
There's no weird parkour needed except for one achievement.
One way to find out.
Oh gosh.
No, but those scrawny legs!
Do a double jump.
Yeah, I don't have a jetpack.
Do I have to...
I don't think if I get it over there, I won't be able to jump up onto the...
I don't know how to pull myself up, you know?
I...
I am so sad.
I don't know how to use my arms.
Except for holding things apparently.
Okay.
Maybe...
There's a staircase.
Let's explore a little bit more.
Wait, this is where...
Isn't it in there where the guy is walking around?
Or am I crazy?
Let's go the other way then.
If there's someone walking around on the other side, we'll just...
go this way then.
There's an elevator.
I want to get down there too.
Time to explore just a little bit.
Even though I'm terrified.
I don't like it.
Wait a second!
Can I make it?
Dang it.
Where am I?
Oh.
Oh gosh.
There we go.
Good morning.
Okay, we'll have to watch the thing again.
You can't make it.
Sorry.
No music this time.
But even if I do make it at that point...
There's actually a couple seconds...
before...
There's like a little bit...
before we pass away.
Maybe...
Before the loop consumes us?
Hm.
Which one was it?
No.
Sss.
Sssssssssss.
Was it this one?
No...
Where is it?
Uh oh...
Where is my vision?
It's not this one, right?
No...
Did you see it?
Wait, huh?
Where is the thing?
Is it on a line?
Oh, maybe.
Unless it's at the end of this one, is what I'm checking too.
Let's see if it...
Okay, there's loops.
Oh, the hidden vault?
Yeah, yeah.
Ah, okay.
Hello.
Points to tower.
Go up the tower.
Hello.
Point...
Artifact.
Back downstairs.
In here.
Snooze.
Wake back up.
Those two turn off.
Then we can enter.
Huh?
Oh, oops.
My bad.
Yeah!
That's what I did though, but...
He doesn't show back up with the artifact.
Like I thought he did.
Ikea directions.
Hahaha.
Maybe it's missing something.
Maybe.
Is it okay if I go to the little ghostly's room real quick?
You guys just keep watching this.
And I'm gonna go to the bathroom and I'm also gonna grab a little bit of a snack.
Because my tummy is hungry.
So give me one second.
Here.
Uh...
I'll be right back.
Hahaha.
Give me like five minutes maybe.
Sorry, sorry.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
I have pies with me because she was really sad.
I have her with me.
Right?
Yeah.
You wanted in here so badly.
You're a banana.
Welcome back.
Thank you!
Okay.
I have a snack.
Butter shoyu stick potato.
I'll have some actual dinner afterwards.
Yeah.
And I have my gamer chopsticks.
Have we figured anything out?
You guys said watch it real closely.
And um...
Yep.
Hahaha.
Um...
Do I have to stand in like that corner of the room?
It's giving me visions.
Mm...
Yum yum yum yum yum.
I'm
looking.
What are you looking for?
What are you doing?
Stop it!
Stop!
Stop, don't... oh my god.
She knocked the...
The top of... oh my god.
Stop it, you bad girl.
Stop it.
She might get into some stuff, so...
You wanna lay in my chair?
You wanna go plop over there?
Are you gonna plop?
She plopped.
I tore off the corner of the bag and she knocked it off and started like...
licking it.
I don't know what to do here.
I have no idea.
Oh!
I had to turn off my fishing.
Sorry, my bad.
I have no idea.
I'm stuck.
I'm a little stuck.
I can explore and then come back to the puzzle?
Yeah, but that means I have to go into scary areas again.
I don't know if I wanna do that.
And roll.
Perfection.
You cannot avoid the scary.
Are you sure?
Welcome back, boss.
Thank you.
I always am just a little bit off.
Alright.
What's a scary area?
Oh, my ship.
Okay, hold on.
I didn't even notice that.
What the?
Hold on.
Oh.
Orlando, Idaho.
What are you talking about?
Okay.
Ship log.
Let's see.
Endless Canyon.
Candlelit Lodge is built.
Okay, that was...
I have to remember how to get to these places.
I have to remember how to...
You can explore the one cave with the ghost matter again.
Oh, yeah.
I can.
Do that place.
Risotto.
Thanks for two months.
Thank you.
Oh, my god.
Pies is going kind of crazy.
Starlit cave.
I don't remember which one is which.
I guess we have to explore all three of them.
I guess all of them have something going on.
The light coming out of the vault gave me a vision of climbing a spiral staircase to a room near the top of the tower.
One of the strangers inhabitants pointed at the mural beneath a ringed planet, then picked up an artifact and carried it downstairs to a room with a green fire.
Sometime later, two of the lamps in the mural room turned off, blending the mural into darkness and revealing a secret passage.
Do I have to like...
Is it so specific that I have to like put the artifact there and...
I don't know.
The lodge was the place with the hidden canyon?
I haven't been there.
Oh, yes.
Yes.
We found out the way to get there through the hole.
That's right.
You're right.
I recommend exploring the dark places for more info.
Okay.
We'll just go to the first one then.
We'll just go to the one...
right here at the very beginning.
I feel like I'm not going to sleep tonight.
We'll go to this one here.
Damn this whimsy music.
Screw you.
Grab.
Grab and go.
Speedrun.
Sending my energy.
Thank you.
I need it.
I'm wobbling it up.
I'm a hungry ghost.
Okay.
We'll just go here first.
So maybe if they see me...
They just wake me up.
Maybe.
Right.
You guys aren't going to do anything bad to me.
Right?
Just going to wake me up.
Bet you wish you touched fish.
Shut up.
Okay.
We're back in a place.
Is this the DLC version?
It is.
This is Outer Wilds DLC.
It's very scary.
Yeah.
There's this door here.
Somebody's house.
Oh yes.
This is where this person just gazes.
Into the...
Yup.
Totally normal noise is happening right now.
Everything is pretty normal.
Wake me up.
Wake me up and...
I can't wake up.
Wake me up and save me.
Huh.
Wait.
Extinguish.
Oh.
Interesting.
What happens if I go there now?
Is the door open?
Oh god.
I'm just a maid.
I'm here to clean your room.
Help!
Nothing more, nothing less.
Just regular maid...
maid activities.
Of course.
What the hell is that?
Oh.
Hello.
Let's go really quickly.
My controller is vibrating.
Wait, isn't that the tower I need to go to?
They're idols.
Yeah, they were singing.
Tiger.
Fire.
Cyber.
Fiber.
Diver.
Viber.
Jar Jar.
Look,
I'm a I'm a fan.
I'm a big fan of you guys.
Huge fan.
That's... yeah, that's...
But it's not open.
Good thing we didn't go down there.
Why are we going into another cave?
I'm just... I'm just taking...
Taking it easy.
Oh.
I think this is our stop.
Ah.
Taking it easy.
I want to see where this goes to.
I'm just seeing where it takes us, you guys.
Life is...
Sometimes about not the destination, but the journey.
What's this one?
Wait.
What is this?
Hmm.
I'm intrigued.
By the staircase.
Oh.
Look, we can even summon a new bow.
It's fine.
A rock.
Let's grabby grab.
Okay.
I think I gotta get grabbed by this guy.
Wew!
Okay.
This is where they all just sit and stare at what's going on in here.
Little creepy voyeurs.
That's what they are.
What do I... What's my vision?
Okay.
I'm gonna grab one too.
I did that.
They took it.
Okay.
What's it mean?
So this is where...
Yes, this is where I would respawn.
Yes, yes, yes.
Or like when I go... when I do this part.
Okay.
Yeah, they were carrying something.
They took it downstairs.
It's interesting though because when I leave this...
I am not in this place.
Speedy fire!
Thanks for the farm gift!
Thank you!
Huh.
Oh yes, I went underground, right?
I went...
It was like the subterranean...
No, that's not the lake.
That's not the subterranean lake, is it?
Can I see it though?
Faster.
Maybe we can go to that one platform I missed.
I'm scared.
This is...
a place!
Is this where...
we started?
I think so.
Yeah.
Yeah, this is where we started.
I'm not gonna stop.
And we'll hear them singing again.
I think.
Doing their weird culty whatever.
Weird culty whatever going on in there.
Tiger!
Fire!
Cyber!
Wait, did it mean to...
Wait.
Did it yell before?
I can't remember.
Huh.
Did it...
Did it yell before?
Did it do that scream before?
Huh.
Maybe let's find a boat.
There's one down there.
Or maybe it saw me and then that's why it yelled.
I spooked it maybe.
A boat?
Any boats around?
I feel like we were in there for such a long time.
Before...
Before the dam broke.
Ah, an alien!
Says the alien.
No, they say... Ah, ghost!
I'm stuck.
I'm just waiting for this boat to come on by.
Boat?
Where the hell did it go?
Is it stuck?
Maybe this helps push it.
Hello!
This is so like...
Oh my god, there's the boat!
Are you kidding me?
Hahaha!
It's upside down!
Ah, this is fine.
We'll just ride this.
Here we go.
There we go.
Even better.
Um...
This reminds me of when like I took the...
You know, the river...
The river Styx.
Sanzu no Kawa.
Good times.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah!
And...
Nice.
Time to go back into the creepy world.
But I liked being on the boat.
I felt pretty safe there.
Not gonna lie.
I didn't mind so much being on the boat.
Oops.
I always go the wrong direction.
I kinda liked it.
I kinda felt safe and...
Like it was kinda chill, you know?
Anyways, guys.
See you never, I hope.
See you never, I hope!
Oh.
Uh, here.
But this area has the guy walking around, doesn't it?
Yeah.
I think this is the area where he's walking around upstairs.
Where's the boat at?
Where's the boat?
Okay, there was some guy walking up there.
Someone walking up here too.
Pretty sure.
Will he see me if I walk out here?
I don't know.
There's no windows.
Maybe not.
I can get grabby-grabbed.
Or...
What's down here?
Oh god!
I didn't mean to get grabby-grabbed!
It really scared me.
Oh my god.
Wait, am I on the second floor now?
On the third floor?
But if I grabby-grab over there, I will not be grabby-grabbing back, because there's nothing here!
Let's go back to the other side.
Guys, this is too spooky for me.
Okay.
I wanted to go...
Oh wait.
I have to drop down.
If I drop down, will I...
Wait.
Oh, here we go.
I was gonna say, will I be okay?
I can't read!
Wee woo!
Well...
That...
Now we know.
Maybe...
I have to go through there without any light.
I think.
She got out without dying.
Stop!
You guys are making me so scared!
I'm really so scared!
Well, let's just drop some.
You progress five meters each loop.
That doesn't seem very much.
I'm not really finding anything in the other world.
I mean, I'm trying.
I am looking around.
But I am not finding so much.
Oh, whoops.
That's totally not even related.
Hmm...
You're close.
You just need to figure something.
Okay.
Figuring out one thing at a time does help.
You found the boat.
Last loop in the area with the bell.
This one.
True.
How did I get to the boat?
Oh, wait.
No, I remember.
That was just the normal path that we took.
Let's just go back there.
The boat kind of leads us to everywhere.
It seems pretty nice, actually.
And I know you guys are trying to scare me.
You guys are like, She doesn't know about the boat.
She doesn't know.
Well...
Um...
Whatever.
She doesn't know.
No.
She doesn't know the boat.
But we can go back to the bell.
Or rather...
Wait.
We're trying to figure out the bell on...
On, uh...
From the outside, right?
Or...
Oh my goodness.
I'm forgetting how to play.
I'm forgetting how to drive!
Matching velocity.
And doing a roll.
Perfect.
Don't forget my suit!
Alright,
let's...
I'm getting kind of good at speedrunning this, I think.
Getting a little good at it.
And I've always been good at driving this boat.
Okay.
Let's grab our artifact.
And let's...
Oh!
Whoopsie.
Let's...
Let's fly up.
Let's grab our...
Our artifact.
And...
Drop.
Okay.
This
is...
The boat.
Actually, hold on.
Nevermind.
I was gonna say, does the picture represent where I'm going?
But I don't think so.
Oh.
It's not dark enough.
There we go.
I should have eaten it.
I should have had it anyway.
Good morning!
Nobody.
Good boy.
I mean...
Oh boy.
I am not trying to call...
The aliens a good boy.
That was a mistake.
Meow.
I wish they would pre-put that line back into...
Sonic.
Uh...
Meow.
Alright.
Come on, boat.
What is that?
There's...
Someone over there.
Or was that my...
That wasn't my cursor, was it?
Wait.
Was that the little dot in the middle?
Was that...
Was that the...
It was something, right?
There it is.
Yeah.
It's not my dot at all.
It is.
It was walking.
I saw it.
It wasn't me going crazy.
So there is something walking around in here.
Oh.
No.
Oh, golly.
Taking it slow.
Anywhere to get off?
Or...
No?
Nowhere...
My controller just...
vibrated.
Nowhere to get off.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Act like you belong.
Yeah.
Oh, this one.
This one I wanted to get off...
on before too.
Let's see what happens here.
I think just another...
I think this will call...
probably just another boat, right?
But...
What?
There's also an elevator here.
Hi!
Just calls another boat.
Okay.
That's what I figured.
So...
Basically...
We will come down from up there...
at some point.
Okay.
Ms. Frizzle...
I don't like this field trip.
I don't like it.
This game is so scary.
It's so dark.
And I even turned the brightness up.
So here.
This secret.
They carried that thing down.
There's no one here though, right?
Yeah.
I think.
This calls another boat, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Hmm.
I like how the chains go into non-existence.
I like that.
Yeah.
I noticed that earlier too.
It's just kind of...
You know.
It's by the power of...
God and anime.
Holding up this.
What if I shine it on your planet, huh?
Really bright, huh?
You don't like that, huh?
So this is where...
We teleport into.
And this is the visions.
They kidnap.
They de-thorax Matara.
Essentially.
Hold on.
While this is going on.
I'm gonna check on Pies.
She has wrapped herself.
In a blanket.
She has wrapped herself in a blanket.
She seems okay.
She seems like she's doing alright.
Let's see.
There's like a parkour maybe.
Is there anything even down here though?
Maybe here.
Parkour.
We're fine.
Dang it.
Give you one second.
Oh shoot.
I feel like I'm gonna be trapped here for a while.
I feel like I might have to cook on this a little bit.
I might have to...
think about this a little bit.
I did say I wanted today's stream to be only three hours.
But I feel like...
I mean we learned a lot.
But also I feel like...
I mean we
learned a lot.
You've got everything in dream 4.
Now try dream 2, 3, or 1.
Wait this is 4?
2, 3, or 1.
There's that one.
And...
Was there one over here?
There's this house right here.
That we have to enter through the other way.
And uh...
Don't think there was anyone here either.
And
uh...
There it goes.
Destroying everything.
Oh, am I in trouble?
No, we're okay!
That was so giddy giddy.
That was really close actually.
We're alright!
Giddy giddy safe.
Hmm...
I'm gonna try...
Well that part's all gonna be destroyed in just a second, isn't it?
We're gonna watch it all get...
Yep, there it goes!
There it goes!
But I think we can still go in there.
So there's a couple things that we need to figure out.
One is the...
The ghost matter cave.
What's the matter?
What's the ghost matter cave?
Oh my gosh.
Have you guys heard of...
Have you heard of the matter baby?
What's the matter baby?
I don't know.
What's the matter with you?
The matter baby!
What's the matter baby?
The ghost matter baby.
This way, this way, this way...
Push, push, push!
Nice, nice, nice.
Artifact, you okay?
Yep.
All good.
Anyway...
I actually can't remember...
Which way it was.
I think it's...
That one up there maybe?
No, that's the projector room.
Up here maybe?
I think we can't...
Get up there.
No wait, that's uh...
Is there no...
Sleepy guys in this area?
Sleepy...
Deer bird people in your area?
You can jump the bridge for sure from the top.
But can we get to the top?
The real question.
What?
I think I thought I was going somewhere but I...
Went the wrong...
Oh wait!
This is the cave...
This is a cave.
What was in here again?
Oh gosh.
Okay, I feel like I need to start taking notes or something.
It's a little overwhelming.
It's a lot of infor...
Oh, it's up there!
There it is!
Okay, okay, okay.
If we can get to the top.
Oh wait, this way, this way, this way.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
Come on, come on!
I don't know if I can make that!
No!
The river's too strong.
You know what, since we're here, let's go to the bell.
Oh my god, I thought that was a...
dancing egg again.
I thought there was an egg on my screen.
What are you up to currently?
I don't know.
I've never played this game.
Or this DLC before.
I have no idea.
What I'm up to, what I'm down to.
Down to clown.
That's what I'm always down to.
Always down to clown, baby.
Good morning!
Then they took it downstairs.
I don't see any doors or anything around here though.
We must also go downstairs.
We can't go through there.
We have to...
What is that?
We have to seal that up somehow.
I imagine.
Unless...
Do we...
Does it like seal up when...
When like the things fall or whatever, I wonder.
I'm gonna seal it up with...
Gosh, what's that stuff?
A guy like slams it on the ground?
Or on the...
Not flex tape.
Maybe it is flex tape.
Oh, it is flex tape!
Yeah, we're gonna...
With the flex tape.
Plants...
It's really peaceful over here.
There's also a boat.
I wonder if I have to wait for like...
Oh!
Do they scream when the tower falls?
Interesting.
But nothing covers it up.
Oh!
Goodness gracious.
I'm sorry.
Have you ever heard of...
Good dog?
What's that?
Can I conceal it and go into the water?
Actually, let's try it.
Since we're about to die anyway.
Nope.
I guess worth a shot.
Oh, what's good, dog?
What's good, dog?
You're cooking though, in any case.
I'm trying.
I think I'm gonna have to cook.
I think I'm gonna have to...
Let this one...
Sit in my brain for...
Until next time.
I think.
Marinate.
We'll continue next week.
We'll finish it next week.
Hmm.
You're close.
I don't even know what I'm close to though.
I've got to figure stuff out.
Okay.
So I am still missing something.
I mean...
I figured, but...
One place we also need to go back to...
Is that one place that...
Had the guy watching TV.
Yeah.
Close to like five things.
I don't even know what I'm close to.
I wish...
I miss when my biggest mystery was...
What was firing out of that cannon.
I wish when that...
I wish...
I miss...
I miss when that was the biggest mystery.
But I'll go through some of this stuff.
And figure it out.
Or try to figure it out.
I will cook.
Until...
Until I can cook no longer.
Until it is burnt, fried...
Unrecognizable.
The arrows give you info.
Yeah.
Projection.
It reveals a cave entrance at the base of a rocky island with a tall tower.
Yeah.
I went there.
I saw that.
I totally did that.
I can't figure out this dang tower!
You!
You stinkin' tower.
The hidden vault seals.
Why can't they just show me the code?
They wrote their password on the wall.
Why can't they show me also the password?
In their projection as well.
In the visions, huh?
Why can't they show me there too?
You're making plenty of progress.
Just keep going.
I will.
I will next week.
Mhm.
Yeah.
It's really fantastic watching you play through this game.
Your enthusiasm and energy are top tier!
You'll figure it out soon.
Thank you!
Ah!
I want to keep going, but I do need to get some good sleep tonight.
That's what I will be doing.
I will be cutting it off here.
I even went a little bit over what I was planning on.
Oh, how naive I was to think that I would solve this in two streams.
But that's okay.
It is what it is.
I also have some work that I have to do.
So I'm going to go do that before I go to sleep.
Thank you guys for joining me again today!
I hope you guys...
Your brains are hurting as much as mine is.
We learned so much though.
Like a crazy amount.
It was very interesting to It was very interesting to go into the spooky world and finally get the spookiness of the DLC.
Thanks for streaming!
It always makes me smile.
Thank you!
Have a good rest and well soon.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you for your hard work!
And tomorrow is chill.
Tomorrow is fun.
No brain hurty game of deal or no deal.
So, otsuminto everybody!
Thank you!
I would stick around more.
Luckily this tea is helping my throat a whole lot.
But I'm going to go rest my voice now.
I had double streams today too.
So...
It's been a busy day.
Otsuminto!
Have a good night everybody!
Thank you for helping me out!
We'll solve more mysteries next time.
Bye bye!
Wait...
Okay, pause is still in the blanket.
Bye bye!